das ist das spektakulärste astronomische
ereignis des jahres die große
konjunktion zwischen den planeten
jupiter und saturn
das letzte mal vor 400 jahren befanden
sich die beiden riesen in einer so nahen
spektakulären konstellation die
vielleicht auch den stern von bethlehem
erklären könnte wie und woher das
faszinierende schauspiel von saturn und
jupiter am himmel sehen könnt erfahrt
ihr jetzt hier bei klicksafe wird hier
gibt es drei mal pro woche spannende
science videos aber nicht den kanal oder
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
bei diesem video ist übrigens team von
astro comics tv mit dabei dessen channel
ihr unbedingt abonnieren solltet wenn
ihr euch für den weltraum interessiert
ich habe hier oben für euch verlinkt
also hier draufklicken und abonnieren im
sommer war der komet neo weist die
absolute sensation mit bloßem auge
konnte man ihn am himmel sehen
ich selbst habe ihn hier vom dach aus in
berlin beobachtet aber das jahr 2020 hat
zum abschluss noch ein weiteres
astronomisches super highlight parat die
große konjunktion von jupiter und saturn
dieses planetare ronny wo ist nur alle
20 jahre sichtbar und gehört daher zu
den sehr seltenen astronomischen
ereignissen und fasziniert die
menschheit schon seit jahrtausenden aber
wie kommt es überhaupt dazu dass jupiter
und saturn sich am himmel treffen können
die erde umkreist auf ihrer bahn die
sonne von unserer position aus können
wir weit entfernte stern am himmel sehen
aus denen antike kulturen sich die
sternbilder ausgedacht haben die sterne
unseres nachdem es sind viele lichtjahre
entfernt auf eine solch große entfernung
können wir so gut wie keine bewegung der
sterne wahrnehmen im verhältnis
zueinander
bleiben sie selbst über jahrhunderte
fast identisch der große wagen sieht
heute noch fast genauso aus wie er im
jahr 1800 außer ganz anders sieht das
bei den anderen planeten unseres
sonnensystems aus da diese sich viel
näher an unserer erde befinden und ja
ebenfalls um die sonne kreisen verändern
sie ihre position am himmel
ein bekanntes beispiel ist die venus je
nach position im umlauf um die sonne
erscheint sie von der erde aus als
morgenstern und kann kurz vor
sonnenaufgang beobachtet werden oder
eben als abendstern der in der zeit der
dämmerung beobachtet werden
die venus verändert ihre position am
himmel schnell da sie ihn nur 225 erden
tagen einmal die sonne umrundet jupiter
und saturn hingegen haben es so gar
nicht eilig auf ihrer bahn um die sonne
ein jahr auf jupiter entspricht 12
erdenjahre saturn benötigt sogar 29
erdenjahre für eine umdrehung um unseren
stern das führt dazu dass die beiden
gasriesen ihre scheinbare position von
der erde aus nur sehr langsam verändern
doch alle 20 jahre kommt es zu einem
außergewöhnlichen treffen am irdischen
himmel jupiter und saturn scheinen dann
direkt übereinander zu stehen und bilden
einen beeindruckenden hellen punkt am
himmel ein solches zusammentreffen von
himmelskörpern von der erde aus gesehen
bezeichnet man als konjunktion da sich
hier um ein zusammentreffen der beiden
größten planeten handelt spricht man
folgerichtig von der großen konjunktion
grundsätzlich treffen sich die beiden
gasriesen alle 20 jahre
doch manchmal sind sie noch ein bisschen
näher beieinander als sonst dieses jahr
haben wir eine solch besonders nahe
große konjunktion das letzte mal als der
saturn und der jupiter sich derart nah
bei einem zusammentreffen waren war bei
der großen konjunktion im jahr 1623 wir
erleben also ein astronomisches ereignis
das es so in den letzten knapp 400
jahren nicht gegeben hat und obwohl es
die nächste kollektion bereits im jahr
2040 geben wird wird es zu einer derart
nahen begegnung der beiden planeten wie
in diesem jahr erst 2080 kommen das
werden also nur die jüngeren von uns
noch erleben wer die große konjunktion
also dieses jahr verpasst wird sehr
lange auf die nächste gelegenheit warten
müssen deswegen wird euch team von astro
comics tv nun erklären wo und wann er
hinschauen müsst um das ereignis optimal
sehen zu können so ein gigantisches der
disco wir hinter mir seht in unserer
sternwarte das braucht ihr zum glück gar
nicht um die große konjunktion
beobachten zu können man sich dieses
spektakel nämlich auch wunderbar mit
bloßem auge die beiden planeten die
werden dann zu einem sehr hellen punkt
am himmel verschmelzen das ganze sieht
aus wie ein super heller stern nur dass
es sich eben nicht um einen stern handel
sondern und
planeten jupiter und saturn den
höhepunkt erreicht das ganze am 21
dezember an diesem tage wird das gar
nicht zu übersehen sein weil die
wirklich einen leuchtend teller punkt am
himmel sein werden wer das planetare
runde wo beobachten möchte der sollte ab
15.30 seinem blick gen südwesten richten
ich habe unsere kuppel schon in richtung
südwesten aufgemacht und die große
konjunktion ist auch schon im
dämmerlicht zu erkennen so helen sind
die beiden planeten das zeitfenster in
dem ihr die große konjunktion sehen
könnt das wird allerdings immer kürzer
mitte dezember sind die beiden planeten
noch bis 19 uhr zu sehen also dann gehen
sie es unter am ersten weihnachtstag
sind sie schon um 18 uhr vollständig
untergegangen für diejenigen von euch
die sich mit sternbildern auskennen
lässt sich das ereignis auch mit hilfe
der konstellation am himmel lokalisieren
hier seht ihr wie sich das ereignis am
21.12 um 17 uhr 30 darstellen wird die
beiden planeten befinden sich dann von
der erde aus gesehen genau zwischen den
sternbildern steinbock und schützen
kurz nach sonnenuntergang werdet ihr
vielleicht schon die beiden hellen
sterne alitalia und formal haut sehen
können diese bilden gemeinsam mit der
großen konjunktion an dreieck am himmel
dass ihr sicherlich gut finden könnt ihr
könnt die große konjunktion wie gesagt
sehr gut mit bloßem auge sehen wenn ihr
aber doch ein teleskop habt es muss auch
gar nicht hier so eine riesen teil sein
dann solltet ihr auf jeden fall mal
versuchen die beiden planeten durch die
linse ins visier zu nehmen das kann
nämlich richtig spektakulär aussehen ihr
könnt dann vielleicht einzelne
jupitermonde erkennen die galinesen
monde oder sogar die ringe vom saturn in
hoher auflösung beobachten das ist
wirklich ein faszinierender anblick ich
wünsche euch viel glück und spaß beim
auffinden und beobachten der großen
konjunktionen wenn ihr noch detailfragen
zur genauen positionen damit habt dann
schreiben sie uns gerne in die
kommentare
die große konjunktion passt übrigens
perfekt zur weihnachtszeit denn einige
forschende glauben dass sie eine
astronomische erklärung für den stern
von bethlehem sein könnte laut dem
matthäusevangelium sind die drei
heiligen könige einer hellen
himmelserscheinung gefolgt und haben so
das jesuskind gefunden schon seit jeher
rätselt die wissenschaft darüber worum
es sich bei diesem biblischen
himmelsphänomen gehandelt haben könnte
in den meisten darstellungen wird der
weihnachtsstern als eine art meteor oder
comet dargestellt teilweise wird sogar
vertreten dass es sich um eine weit
entfernte supernovas also einen
explodierenden stern gehandelt haben
könnte doch die meisten vorstände gehen
tatsächlich davon aus dass damals im
heiligen land eine konjunktion von
jupiter und saturn sichtbar gewesen sein
könnte
man kann anhand der umlauf daten von
saturn und jupiter berechnen dass es im
jahre sechs vor christus zu einer großen
konjunktion kam gleichzeitig den viele
historiker und historikerinnen davon aus
dass jesus gar nicht im jahre null
sondern im jahre sechs vor christus
geboren wurde und nicht nur das im jahre
sechs vor christus kam es zu einer so
genannten größten konjunktion sozusagen
der steigerung einer großen konjunktion
da die erde als innerer planet schneller
unterwegs ist als die äußeren planeten
saturn und jupiter kann es passieren
dass sie diese auf der bahn um die sonne
überholt wenn das geschieht sieht es für
einen irdischen beobachter so aus als
würden jupiter und saturn sich am himmel
rückwärts bewegen dieses phänomen nennt
beim planeten schleifen ganz ganz selten
kann es auf diese art und weise
geschehen dass jupiter und saturn sich
derart am himmel vorgerückt bewegen dass
sie sich in einem jahr gleich dreimal
treffen genau zu einem solchen spektakel
am himmel kam es im jahr sechs vor
christus so dass es nicht
unwahrscheinlich ist dass dies den
heiligen drei königen die in der bibel
als gelehrte beschrieben werden
aufgefallen ist ihm und ich wünschen
euch viel erfolg beim beobachten der
begegnung von saturn und jupiter und
natürlich eine frohe weihnachtszeit
andere astronomische erklärung für den
stern von bethlehem zum beispiel eine
supernova explosion erklärt euch tim in
diesem video hier also unbedingt drauf
klicken um in weihnachtsstimmung zu
kommen und natürlich nicht vergessen den
kanal von astor comics tv zu abonnieren
also hier und ihm zu helfen sein ziel
von 40.000 abonnenten zu erreichen bis
dann bleibt dran